l'année 2016 a été riche sur le plan
culturel à saint quentin en yvelines
avec bien sûr des têtes d'affiché en
janvier c'est claude brasseur qui joue
sur la scène du théâtre espace coluche
de plaisir le même mois n'a todd
l'auteure américaine téléchargée plus
d'un milliard de fois dédicacer sa
nouvelle saga des fonds noirs une
écriture simple le style inimitable du
dessinateur benz découvrez à travers une
exposition à la maison elsa triolet
l'artiste s'interroger sur la vérité
c'est un peu comme l'était un peu un peu
quelque chose à moi c'est que un à dix
candidats on compte que il est toujours
à la recherche de la gloire et est à la
recherche de lui même et à loger des
choses donc un moment donné ils s'aiment
pas beaucoup mais il peut pas faire
autrement
la scène musicale n'est pas en reste
général elektriks à la batterie de
guyancourt andré manoukian et china
moses au prisme brigitte fontaine sur la
scène du théâtre national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines et des têtes
d'affiché mais pas seulement cette
saison 2016 a vu des yvelines on a
révélé cécilia de ar c est une jeune
réalisatrice tout juste sorti de l'école
d'elancourt 3 i/s son court métrage une
sur trois a été primé au festival
international du court métrage de
clermont ferrand
cet été les filles du collectif de
simone remporté un prix au festival off
d'avignon leur pièce c'est un peu
compliqué d'être à l'origine du monde
est soutenu par le prisme des longs
cours le 23 mai dernier eric bouvron
sauter comme un fou l'yvelinois
d'adoption remporte le molière du
théâtre privé pour les cavaliers
je pense parce que ça amener quelque
chose différent dans le monde du théâtre
privé qui n'a pas toujours le canapé et
les têtes d affiche c'était vraiment une
équipe qui mène une histoire qu'à
certains pourfendeurs dans une manière
je pense assez originale toujours
molière mais cette fois pour le festival
théâtral il fêté cette année ses 20 ans
une exposition retraçant son histoire
lui était consacrée aux archives de la
ville et la charrette a fait son retour
il ya vingt ans quand j'ai lancé le moi
c'était avec francis perrin
j'ai demandé à francis d'être en
charrette comme comme molière ou fond il
avait été extraordinaire mais là pour le
20e anniversaire on s'est dit on va
reprendre des charrettes le château de
la cité royale a aussi vu la réouverture
de sa galerie des carrosses après neuf
ans de fermeture et grâce à un mécénat
elle dévoile à nouveau ses joyaux
au trot réouverture celle de la
médiathèque du canal à montigny le
bretonneux
après 18 mois de travaux les salles sont
chaleureuses et les outils d'emprunt
plus simplifié le rêve de tout
responsable de mediatek est de voir son
établissement
fréquenter lisible facile
d'utilisation de voir un public curieux
renouveler intéressés par ce qu'on peut
proposer une saison aussi pour rendre
hommage depuis le 7 novembre les curieux
peuvent redécouvrir raymond devos la
maison de l'artiste à
saint-rémy-lès-chevreuse a été
transformée en musée 2016 c'était aussi
la première commémoration des attentats
qui ont touché paris le 13 novembre 2015
plusieurs jours de concerts notamment au
scarabée de la verrière
un rendez vous qui a attiré plus de 400
spectateurs
les bénéfices ont été reversés aux
victimes et à leurs familles
elle allait 2016 aura aussi vu partir
michel tournier écrivain français
l'auteur de vendredi où la vie sauvage
s'est éteint le 18 janvier à choisel
élevé zighoud d'un gotlib nous a aussi
quitté
il était l'auteur de gai luron et des
dingos dossier